Counter-Strike is known for its visceral
and satisfying gun play
now firing a weapon looks pretty simple
you click your mouse your character
shoots your target takes damage
but there's a lot more happening behind
the scenes in previous versions of
Counter-Strike the game only evaluated
moving and shooting in discrete time
intervals or ticks and time between
those ticks didn't exist
for the most part the experience was
seamless but sometimes those
milliseconds between click and tick
could be the difference between Landing
or missing your shot
that's why with Counter-Strike 2 we're
introducing subtic updates
now the tip rate no longer matters for
moving and shooting so the server will
know the exact moment you fired your
shot jumped your jump or peaked your pee
and the server will calculate your
precise actions between ticks
so what you see is what you get
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]